course we're also keeping a close eye on
the balance of power in carson city
democrats right now controlling both the
state senate and the state assembly but
they appear to at this point to maybe be
losing some of that control
i-team reporter david charns taking a
look at that balance of power for us
tonight david
yeah so denise we are waiting for those
results locally to come in but this is
how the
balance of power looks right now of
course last night a good night for
republicans looking like they gained
seats
in the state senate this is what the
race would be this is what the balance
would be
if that election were called right now
democrats
losing a seat or two it would be 11 to
10 again that's best case scenario for
the gop
over to the state assembly it's a little
bit different democrats have more
control but it's no longer
a super majority likely a 26 to
16 spread there let's talk about some
local races where you live
in senate district six this is northwest
las vegas
this is the state senate majority leader
nicole canazzaro
she's in a really close race here to her
republican opponent april becker just
500 votes there district five in open
seat in henderson
right now it's leading republican carrie
buck but we are awaiting that good chunk
of votes in clark county for both of
those races
closer look at state assembly races now
republican heidi kasima leading her
opponent here district two by several
points
to district four republican richard
mcarthur running ahead of democratic
incumbent connie monk to district 31
that's in washoe
we're looking at democrat skip daley
losing right now to his republican
challenger jill
dickman and district 37 shay backus
likely losing hersey to andy matthews
now review journal political editor and
channel 8 political analyst steve
sebelius tells us
this means that democrats will have to
make some concessions
neither side is going to be happy with
that compromise
but then again that's the very
definition of compromise you don't get
everything you want and maybe these
results will push us in that direction
and losing that super majority also
means they'll need bipartisan support
passing any kind of new taxes
but keep in mind with these results
democrats still control the governorship
and both chambers of the state house and
before i let you go do want to
let you know that arizona presidential
race called for joe biden
and denise and brian all joe biden needs
to get to 270
is our six electoral votes back to you